[Musique]
la ferrari habitants commencent déjà à
faire des dégâts ary abittan en garde à
vue du comédien ary abittan l'ontario
mais les stars y habitant a placé en
garde à vue si certaines chaînes ont
fait le choix de ne pas déprogrammer les
programmes dans lequel l'acteur
humoriste apparaissait comme son one man
show sur tmc la semaine dernière
ou encore le film qu'est ce qu'on a pas
au bon dieu diffusée dimanche soir sur
tf1
autre production cependant décidé de
totalement l'évincer c'est le cas des
missiles qui avait commencé à tourner
une série dans laquelle arrêt habitants
figurèrent ary abittan va être remplacé
dans une série pour m6 les scènes vont
donc devoir être tourné avec un autre
comédien et il s'agirait de jonathan
zaccaï acteurs de la série à succès
canal le bureau des légendes avant
coup dur quarry habitants qui voit aussi
sa tournée qui devait débuter
aujourd'hui à versailles largement
compromise alors arrêt habitants écarté
d'une série pour m6 comprenez vous cette
décision
rendez vous cette décision et des infos
alors est ce que je comprends cette
décision
[Musique]
d'un ton info non mais là c'est là la
pauvre non mais laissez tomber on avait
les infos les ados n'a donc vous êtes
favorable à cette décision mais il
n'avait pas le choix vous imaginez le
thème de la série c1 mêmes c'est un mec
qui arnaquent les femmes elles sans
violence mais qui les arnaques donc
c'est injouable la lui n'est pas en état
de tourner ils se terrent ils se terrent
dans la région parisienne et la
production évidemment ne peut pas le
faire et vous êtes sous le nom mais il
n'y a pas un nom malheureusement oui bon
c'est bon merci attention c'est pas très
cher c'est une série sepang avec le
moins qu'aux deux cartons
merci
gruss non mais c'est peut-être c'est
peut-être injuste mais c'est la réalité
le tournage il a lieu en ce moment est
ce que vous imaginez ary abittan se
rendre sur un plateau de tournage est ce
que vous imaginez à bitar et habitant
monter sur scène c'est peut-être injuste
la présomption d'innocence il faut le
rappeler mais c'est la réalité et comme
le dit isabelle la thématique de la
série l'histoire que raconte la série
c'est une phrase une femme sous emprise
psychologique c'est une histoire qui est
compliqué à raconter avec arrêt
habitants coller à la lumière des
accusations dont il fait l'objet dans
quoi je trouve ça injuste mais après un
jour on a fait un tabac sur les médias
et tout était le premier à dire que
c'est dégueulasse que les temps
d'attenté ray sa carrière que les médias
est aujourd'hui mais comme il est venu
en ce sens
adieu depuis depuis l'achat
mathieu c'est injuste mais c'est
compréhensible est-ce que tu imagines
gré aujourd'hui ary abittan monter soi
même c'est bon là alors qu'il est dans
la tourmente et oh oui ça
je sais pas dans quel état ils aiment et
ce que je sais c'est qu'effectivement si
ça avait été l'inversé on aurait fait
ici m6 fait du buzz et ils font du buzz
pour faire barrer le téléfilm dont dans
tous les grands joueurs dont moi je
pense qu'effectivement côté une affaire
comme ça aussi importante voilà il faut
pour qu'on arrête un peu d'en parler
faut se mettre un petit peu ouverts
écarté la personne et que
sur le film le problème c'est que les
tournages sont actuellement donc si ils
mettent des séries en fin d'été les
épices
des épisodes en boîte et qu'ensuite il
est jugé coupable ça va être compliqué
après de les voir et de les diffuser
donc je pense que s'ils tiennent
vraiment à leurs acteurs s'ils tiennent
vraiment à leur acteur principal je
pense qu'ils auraient pu décaler le
tournage en attendant d'avoir le mail
vous mobiliser des équipes
l'argent
mais pas sur
tel